voilà on va démarrer si vous voulez bien
tant pis pour ceux qui nous rejoindront
voilà Mesdames Messieurs mon cher Jean
je suis très très heureux et c'est un
privilège d'introduire cette table ronde
consacré à
l'écoanxiété organisé conjointement donc
avec la commission affaires sociales je
remercie le le président Philippe
Mouillet d'avoir bien voulu coorganiser
et pour l'avoir évoqué précédemment avec
Catherine deoch qui était président de
cette commission merci à eux avoir bien
sûr accepté d'organiser cette réunion
commune pour croiser à la fois les avis
des expertises les approches de nos
commissions sur un sujet un phénomène
qui relève à la fois de la santé du
suivi des politiques publiques en
matière climatique et environnementale
et je ve parler de l'écoanxiété et pour
vous dire la vérité en fait j'ai
souhaité c'est à ma demande que cette
réunion est organisée j'en ai fait la
demande il y a un peu plus d'un an après
la lecture d'un ouvrage par rédigé par
un une de vos confrère euh qui qui et je
le dis en passant mais c'est c'est à son
importance vous comprendrez qui m'avait
été offert par mes enfant et j'ai
découvert cet aspect ou cette définition
de
l'écoanxiété et il m'a semblé non
seulement pertinent mais important
essentiel que nous puissions au sein de
nos commissions évoquer sujet je va pas
tout développer mais quand on sait
aujourd'hui que plus d'un tiers de de
nos enfants ne souhaitent pas eux-même
avoir des enfants pour un certain nombre
de raisons dont celle qu'on va évoquer
que ces phénomènes des coup anxiété et
notamment amplifié par le covid on on
ont vu un afflux
euh et je l'ai constaté à titre
personnel en visitant des établissements
un accroissement de plus de 25 % de la
présence et et des besoins des des
jeunes en matière de de soins et de
suivie psychiatrique et tous ces élément
y concour donc ça me semblait important
que nous puissions avoir un regard
lucide sur ces questions en tant que
législateur en tant que membres de nos
deux
commissions c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs à ma connaissance qu'une
assemblée parlementaire organise une
table ronde d'experts et de praticiens
sur les conciété dans le but d'assurer
l'information du Sénat et du public à
propos d'un concept relativement neuf
mais déjà bien présent dans le débat
public il est en effet entré en
dictionnaire en 2023 la définition qu'en
donne le Robert renvoie à laaconiquement
à l'anxiété provoquée par les menaces
environnementales qui pèsent sur notre
planète en 2021 une étude du lanat
révélit que sur 10000 jeunes de 16 à 25
ans interrogés dans une dizaine de pays
près de la moitié déclaré que le
changement climatique les rendait triste
anxieux en colère un puissant et
coupable avec un pic à 92 % des jeunes
Philippins qui jugent que l'avenir est
effrayant en France ce taux s'élève à 74
% de nos jeunes de 16 à 25 ans dans son
rapport annuel sur l'état de la France
en 2023 le Conseil économique social et
environnemental dresse un bilan des
inquiétudes des Français qui se
concentrre en priorité sur la hausse des
inégalités sociales et la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat mais également le
sentiment d'anxiété face au dérèglement
climatiques le C le 16 indique ainsi que
si les Français sont plutôt optimistes
quand ils pensent à leur propre avenir
ils sont au contraire plutôt pessimistes
quand ils pensent à l'avenir de leurs
enfants ils sont encore davantage quand
ils pensent à l'avenir de la France ou
de la planète face à ces constats
préoccupants il nous a semblant opportun
d'organiser une table ronde pour faire
le point sur la réalité de ce phénomène
avec lucidité et espérance afin de
définir et délimiter la notion
d'éco-anxiété avant éventuellement
d'envisager les réponses publiques qui
pourraient être apportées afin de
circonscrire sa progression et répondre
à cet enjeu croissant à la fois en terme
d'information du public de prévention de
santé publique et de prise en charge
afin d'explorer ces questions nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir ce matin cé
Massini psychiatre à Paris et
neurosciences vous nous détaillerez
Antoine pellissolo psychiatre professeur
des
unités du ghu Henry Mondor tout deux
ouvrage auteur de l'ouvrage les émotions
du règlement climatique manuel Santa
Marina psychologue clinicienne et
psychothérapeute et Pierre-Éric Suter
psychologue du travail dans le but de
permettre à chaque intervenant de
présenter ses travaux et les constats
qu'il a pu tirer de sa pratique et de
son expérience je commencerai par
quelques questions avant de laisser la
parole à à Jean pour amorcer le dialogue
avec nos deux commissions quel réalité
recourvre la notion descoanxiété
fait-elle l'objet d'un consensus
scientifique ou faut-il lui préférer une
autre qualification comment la
diagnostiquer quels sont les symptômes
les plus fréquents quelles sont les
catégories de population les plus
suscepties d'êt concerné on a beaucoup
parlé des jeunes quel sont selon vous
l'ampleur et la dynamique du phénomène
les plusir publi ont-ils selon vous déjà
pris en compte les problématiques
soulevées par cette question nouvelle je
ne serai donc pas plus long je laisse la
parole à Jean puis ensuite nos
différents
intervenants monsieur le le
vice-président chers Didier mesdames et
messieurs mais mes chers collègues
bonjour je voudrais donc au nom du du
président Philippe mouiller qui regrette
de ne pouvoir être présent du fait d'une
cérémonie d'hommage qui doit se tenir
aux Invalides dans quelques instants je
tiens tout d'abord à remercier le
président longjot pour l'initiative de
cette table ronde ainsi que les
participants madame Massini monsieur
[Musique]
pissolo monsieur Suter et et Madame
Santa Marina merci de de votre présence
j'espère que nos échanges nous
permettront de mieux éclairer les
membres de nos commissions respectives
sur un phénomène émergent dont on peine
à prendre la la pleine mesure je ne
diraiis que peu de mots pour compléter
le propos introductif de de mon collègue
Didier Mandelli j'aimerais peut-être
simplement que vous puissiez préciser en
quoi l'écoanxiété se distingue si tel
est bien le cas des sources d'anxiété
qui ont pu affecter les générations
précédent comme par exemple la guerre
nucléaire l'écoanxiété postell par sa
nature par la quantité des personnes
touchées ou par les troubles qui la
caractérisent des problèmes vraiment
spécifiques je n'en dirai pas davantage
et vous cède donc la
parole bonjour mesdames et messieurs je
suis la docteur céie Massini j'exerce
actuellement en tant que psychiatre de
l'hôpital public à l'hôpital Saint-Anne
situé dans le 14e arrondissement de
Paris dans un service spécialisé dans la
prise en charge des troubles du
comportement alimentaire et je vous
remercie pour cette invitation
j'ai une expérience théorique de la
question qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
via les revues de la littérature
scientifique que j'ai réalisé d'abord
pour ma thèse de médecine puis pour mon
mémoire de fin d'étude travaux tous deux
dirigés par le professeur Antoine
pellissolo ici présent mon mémoire mis à
jour pour la Table Ronde d'aujourd'hui
posz l'une de vos questions l'écoanxiété
est-elle une nouvelle entité clinique ma
thèse elle s'intéressait à l'ensemble
des impacts du dérèglement climatique
sur la santé mentale des populations
dont l'écoanxiété est une des
manifestations le dérèglement climatique
touche déjà la santé mentale de toutes
et tous et ce au-delà de la question de
l'écoanxiété à chaque période de
canicule de sécheresse et à chaque
confrontation à des événements
climatiques extrêmes pour ne citer que
ces trois exemple notre territoire a été
frappé par de nombreuses catastrophes
naturelles ces dernières années et les
études montrent que dans de telles
circonstances il y a davantage de
blessés psychiques que physique pour
citer un exemple de ces blessures
psychiques
15 % des victimes développeront un état
de stress post-traumatique suite à la
confrontation à une catastrophe
naturelle pourtant les dispositifs mis
en place ne reflètent pas cette
répartition et nous en avons fait
l'expérience lors de la pandémie de
covid-19 avec la fermeture de nombreuses
structures en psychiatrie nous
continuons à ce jour de prendre en
charge des patients et patientes dont la
santé mentale a été fortement ébranlée
lors de la
pandémie et ce point en soulignant de
taille les conséquences de ce que nous
traversons sur le plan psychique sont
souvent des conséquences au long cours
qui peuvent nous impacter sur des années
et nécessiter parfois des prises en
chargge tout aussi longues bien que
variaable en intensité les pistes de
réponses que nous allons ébaucher
aujourd'hui devront relever ce défi du
temps long pour être efficiente se poser
la question de la prise en charge de
l'écoanxiété c'est donc poser la
question plus large de la prise en
charge psychiatrique de toutes les
personnes qui en ont besoin aujourd'hui
en France le système de santé n'arrive
plus à répondre aux besoins en santé
mentale de la pop
de nombreuses personnes toutes détresses
psychiqu confondu n'ont pas accès aux
soins qui seraient nécessaires les
délais d'attente de toutes les
structures publiques s'allongent de
façon exponentielle pour atteindre
plusieurs mois et jusqu'à plus d'une
année notamment en pédopsychiatrie la
fréquentation des urgences
psychiatriques culmine alors qu'en
parallèle de nombreux services ferment
parce que nous ne sommes pas assez
nombreux et nombreuses toute profession
de soins confondus si je cite l'exemple
de la pédopsychiatrie en particulier
c'est parce que les études monde que
parmi les populations les plus
vulnérables à l'éco-anxiété se trouvent
les adolescents et les jeunes adultes et
parce que la pénurie implique la
priorisation des prises en charge sur
des critères de sévérité et d'urgence
elle concerne tout particulièrement la
réflexion autour de l'écoanxiété puisque
cette dernière n'est pas à ce jour un
diagnostic psychiatrique à proprement
parler bien qu'elle puisse être à
l'origine d'une douleur psychique
invalidante et être un facteur
précipitant d'autres troubles mentaux
aujourd'hui la littérature scientifique
définit les anxiété comme la peur
chronique des désastres écologiques à
venir à partir d'études descriptives et
qualitatives nous en connaissons
certains symptômes avons des indices sur
sa prévalence et les populations qui
seraient les plus vulnérables des
échelles ont été construites afin de
permettre le développement de la
recherche et d'assurer une comparativité
des résultats néanmoins à ce jour les
connaissances restent limitées ces
manifestations ne sont pas reconnues
comme une pathologie psychiatrique et il
n'y a pas de critère diagnosti définis
permettant d'unifier nos pratiques
toutes les échelles d'évaluation
existant à ce jour n'ont pas été
traduites et validées en français les
études pour permettre de mieux
circonstcrire ce phénomène et définir
comment le prendre en charge sur le plan
thérapeutique n'ont pas encore été menés
ou si elles existent leurs résultat pas
encore publié sur ce sujet il y a donc
un double chantier à mener celui de la
caractérisation de ce trouble et celui
de la mise en place d'action de
prévention et de prise en charge adaptée
pour résumer en trois points clés 1
l'écoanxiété est une des conséquences
sur la santé mentale du dérèglement
climatique il est attendu que les
besoins de soins psychologiques et
psychiatriques augmente du fait du
dérèglement climatique de aujourd'hui la
psychiatrie publique n'est pas en mesure
de répondre aux besoins déjà existant de
la population 3 l'éco-anxiété est encore
insuffisamment défin pour penser des
politiques de santé efficaces sur ce
sujet il reste des travaux de recherche
à entreprendre pour définir des critères
diagnostiques traduire et valider les
échelles existantes en français
comprendre comment l'écoanxiété
s'articule avec les autres troubles
psychiatriques déjà décrits et définir
des stratégies thérapeutiques
efficientes merci pour votre
attention merci je vous laisse
poursuivre
merci bien Messieurs les Présidents
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs euh Antoine péissolo donc
je suis psychiatre chef du service de
psychiatrie à l'hôpital Henry Mondor à
créteille euh je suis pour être
transparent par ailleurs engagé
politiquement donc je signale quand même
que je suis premier adjoint maire de
créteille et secrétaire national du du
Parti socialiste c'est je pense pas
qu'il y a de conflit d'intérêt mais
c'est ça expliquera aussi peut-être la
la complémentarité de certaines approche
et je vous remercie aussi beaucoup de
cette invitation et de l'organisation de
cette table ronde qui à mon sens comme
l' déjà beaucoup souligné SIG Massini
permettra d'insister sur les
problématiques de santé mentale en
général mais avec la le croisement
particulier avec les enjeux du
changement climatique Environnmental en
général euh mon parcours dans cette
problématique ça a été depuis plus de 20
ans de travailler sur l'anxiété en
général sur les troubles anxieux ce
qu'on appelle les les troubles anxieux
c'est les phobies les tocs enfin c'est
ces troubleslà qui peuvent concerner
beaucoup de personnes et parfois être
très invalidant c'est souvent méconnu et
puis petit à petit aussi au travers de
recherches qui sont menées dans notre
équipe à créteille autour de
l'environnement nous pencher sur de plus
en plus de patients souvent jeunes en
effet qui ont cette plainte qui dépasse
juste l'inquiétude parce que
l'inquiétude pour le climat je pense
qu'elle est partagée les chiffres que
vous évoquez qui sont souvent issus de
d'enquêtes ou de sondages sont un petit
peu imprécis en général on a plus de la
moitié de la population générale qui
s'inquiète pour le climat et on peut pas
considérer que c'est une une pathologie
c'est plutôt quelque chose de de de sain
et de d'utile à priori on peut l'espérer
pour euh B l'action à mener en faveur de
la transformation écologique mais au
sein de donc c'est 50 % parfois plus
pour les plus plus jeunes mais ces
personnes-là alors c'est on dit que
c'est pas forcément une souffrance mais
par ex ce que vous évoquez sur le non
désir d'enfant peut être aussi le reflet
quand même d'un d'un impact très fort
alors au sein de ces cette proportion
importante de de personnes conscientes
des enjeux climatiques en effet le
concept d'écoanxiété a émergé on l'a vu
émerger dans les personnes enfin chez
les personnes qui consultent au départ
pour d'autres motifs ou maintenant de
plus en plus pour ce motif là alors il y
a un petit biais je pense qu'on a tous
un BIA ici autour de la table parce que
comme on en parle et qu'on travaille sur
ces questions on voit arriver plus de
personnes avec C ces plaintes là on peut
pas dire du tout qu'on est représentatif
évidemment et en effet on a pas de
chiffrees réellement représentatif
d'épidémiologie la seule étude un peu
récente enfin récente et et à peu près
insistante sur la ce qu'on appelle nous
la prévalence en épidémiologie de ces
troubles défin sur des critères encore
assez fragiles puisque comme on l'a déjà
dit il n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'entité
vraiment reconnu puisque c'est récent et
qu'il faut se méfier de pas
psychiatriser toute la société ça sa que
c'est un un motif de de vigilance mais
en gros les données américaines parce
qu'il y en a pas d'autres je crois dans
le monde sérieuse c'est à peu près 3 %
de la population qui répond à des
critères de pathologie alors critères de
ie c'est sous des formes différentes
mais une anxiété excessive excessive çaà
dire gênante envahissante obsédante avec
souvent des comportements de
vérification qui ressemblent souvent à
des des compulsions qu'on voit dans les
TOC donc des des personnes qui vont
essayer de se rassurer en regardant les
informations et souvent ben c'est pas
l'effet escomé ou en tout cas qui vont
se documenter ils vont regarder les
rapports du JEC et qui vont essayer de
trouver des solutions quelque part et et
ça peut devenir une vraiment quelque
chose d'assez obsédant il y a des
répercussion sur le sommeil sur
l'appétit sur l'équilibre de vie
générale et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là qu'on peut considérer qu'il y
a quelque chose non pas excessif par
rapport à la problématique parce que ça
c'est un jugement comporte par ailleurs
mais sur le retentissement que ça a sur
la personne et c'est là qu'on peut
intervenir nous en tant que soignant
alors justement ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui en terme de prise en charge
c'est relativement je dirais bien
consensuel en tout cas souvent entre les
spécialistes il y a pas mal de choses à
faire je pense qu'on est assez C pour
aider ces personnes parce que les
troubles anxieux on les connaît depuis
longtemps et parce que on a des outils
qui reposent sur les psychothérapies en
général et sur l'accompagnement et avant
tout l'écoute hein c'est c'est
évidemment la première chose que
demandent ces personnes c'est de pouvoir
engager un dialogue des échanges pour
pouvoir légitimer souvent le leur
inquiétude et la partager donc notre
travail c'est d'avoir cette écoute là de
proposer ensuite des soins un peu
spécifiques quand il y a une vraie
pathologie alors là aussi on ressort no
diagnosti de trouble anxieux d'anxiété
généralisée comme on dit de dépression
et parfois et on les soigne ça
normalement les outils classique
fonctionne avec certaines formes de
thérapie notamment assez adapté à cette
problématique autour des thérapies
comportementales et cognitifes pour
faire un petit peu large et puis enfin
il y a vraiment quelque chose que tout
le monde recommande c'est d'accompagner
ces personnes vers une mise en action
vers un engagement qui va correspondre à
leur engagement souvent enfin leur
valeur personnelle la proximité avec la
nature d'une manière générale qui a des
effets bénéfique majeur pour la santé et
la santé psychique et puis un engagement
souvent associatif écologique militant
ou autre permettant de se réaliser et de
sortir de la culpabilité qui est souvent
prégnante alors juste pour terminer pour
répondre un peu une des questions que
vous posiez sur la la différence avec
d'autres formes d'anxiété je pense que
c'est pas encore en effet consensuel ça
reste débattu on est prudent mais je
pense qu'il y a matière effectivement à
définir un un syndrome ou une dimension
un sous-type comme on dit de trouble
anxieux parce que un le motif n'est pas
comme les autres vous évoquez la Guerre
mondiale la guerre nucléaire bon la
petite différence avec la guerre
nucléaire c'est que en tout cas en
grande partie elle n'a pas eu lieu au
sens de effectivement moi je me projette
très bien j'ai j'ai effectivement je
suis parti dans les plutôt des boomers
ici plutôt que des plus jeunes et moi
j'ai offert mon bouquin à mes enfants
pas le contraire mais parce que comme ça
ça Perm té lesémobiliser un peu mais à à
l'époque on était en effet dans cette
idée de la la guerre froide et des des
risques nucléaires il y avait l'espoir
de de l'éviter
puisque réellement on on a pu jusqu'à
présent l'éviter euh là le regard qu'ont
ces personnes sur l'avenir c'est de
toute façon on pourra rien y faire c'est
irrémédiable on peut essayer de dévier
un peu la trajectoire mais on va y on va
y passer et ça ça change un peu
l'appréhension du danger alors ça veut
pas dire que c'est complètement
radicalement différent mais c'est quand
même un vécu particulier qui a des
éléments de désespoir parfois et euh de
mélange des émotions c'est pas que de la
peur il y a souvent la frustration de de
la du désespoir et beaucoup vous savez
bien de ressentiments de colère
notamment envers les autres qui sont
pour certains encore très sceptiqu et
c'est pas c'est pas des films on sait
que le scepticisme il reste encore j'ai
pas enfin je pourrais les citer des
propos récents d'un journaliste qui sur
beaucoup de chaînes en ce moment enfin
en tout cas dans beaucoup de médias qui
assume la France n'a pas s'occuper du du
changement climatique c'est pas son
travail on a de ch à faire c'est
vraiment bon des des discours qu'on
entend et que les anxieux ont du mal
évidemment assumer donc il y a tout
cette particularité là qui je pense
mérite une attention particulière et
pour vraiment terminer une des
propositions je pense que il nous tient
à cœur c'est en effet de travailler sur
cette question au sens alors vraiment
multidisciplinaire c'est pas que une
question de médecin du tout c'est une
question de psychologue de médecin mais
aussi de sociologue de philosophes enfin
de tous les acteurs et notamment les
politiques parce que je pense que les
les deux niveaux que j'évoquéis au
niveau individuel ben il s'applique au
niveau collectif il faut porter la
parole il faut écouter ces ses
préoccupations les
partager légitimer ce qu' doit l'être ou
pas parce que le scénario catastrophe il
est pas forcément celui qu'on va
forcément choisir mais il existe dans la
tête de certaines donc de certains et
donc il y a ces espacces de paroles moi
je pense que je vous parlais de de
l'action locale éventuellement de
d'avoir des lieux d'échange autour de
ces questions là je pense que c'est
primordial et deuxième chose accompagner
vers des meilleures connaissances alors
vers le évidemment l'application des
politiques pour le pour la
transformation climatique c'est la
meilleure chose pour rassurer ces
personnes évidemment puisqueelles sont
inquiètes Eno avec l'idée qu'on fera
rien donc si on montre qu'on est dans
l'action bah ça peut les évidemment les
apaiser un peu et dernière chose mieux
connaître ce ce phénomène moi je
proposerais bien et on est prêt nous à
nous y engager à à créer des alors
c'estis pas des centres ressources un
peu spécialisés des centres de référence
en tout cas qui permettent de travailler
sur les soins apportés sur la
connaissance un peu scientifique et sur
la formation parce que ce qui manque
probablement en tout cas chez les
professionnels qui sont pas pas
spécialisé c'est de connaître tout
simplement et c'est pour ça qu'il est
important d'en parler pour que nos
collègues psychologues médecins tous les
professionnels de santé sachent que
c'est une
problématique réelle authentique qui est
parfois un petit peu je dirais prise de
haut quand on connaît pas bien les
sujets voilà donc il y a je pense des
objectifs universitaires en partie
autour de ça que je pense qu'on pourrait
tout à fait coporter si si vous le
souhaitez pardon d'avoir été un peu
long bonjour Merci beaucoup très honoré
d'être là merci pour l'invitation je
suis du coup Manuela Santa Marina
psychologue clinicienne et
psychothérapeute alors moi je j'ai été
convié je ne suis pas chercheuse donc je
suis psychologue clinicienne
psychothérapeute ça veut dire
concrètement que je suis dans mon
cabinet je reçois des patients je suis
en cabinet libéral et également je
travaille dans une fondation et je vais
prendre un tout petit peu de temps juste
pour décrire un peu d'O d'où je viens et
d'où je par parle pour pour expliquer un
peu mieux après mon mon regard sur cette
situation là je suis alors déjà je suis
tout à fait en accord avec ce qui a été
dit par mes mes premiers collègues
h en gros donc moi à la base je suis
spécialisée en psychotrauma je me suis
intéressée d'un point de vue personnel à
la question de la situation écologique
et des conséquences psychologiques en
2017 et je me suis dit bon je vais
regarder un petit peu ce qui existe en
terme de réponse et en travaux pour
l'accompagnement sur cette thématique et
il y en avait très peu il y en a encore
benah vous en avez entendu euh très peu
en tout cas la question du consensus est
difficile par contre j'ai vu qu'il
existait énormément de de réflexion et
d'accompagnement sur ce sujet mais par
des noms psy par des noms professionnels
de la santé mentale ce qui est quand
même assez euh particulier disons ça
c'està-dire comme s'il y avait un
abandon de la question santé mentale ou
en tout cas un non inérêt à ce moment-là
de la la question de de l'éco-anxiété
alors que il existe depuis longtemps des
réflexions dans d'autres domaines euh du
coup j'ai souhaité personnellement euh
me dire ben comment est-ce que je peux
moi me faire un un regard de cette
clinique au niveau du terrain et j'ai
souhaité rejoindre des mouvements
citoyens écologistes donc c'est aussi un
petit peu important pour moi de vous
dire d' d'où vient mon regard je suis du
coup restée dans ce de ce milieu terrain
pendant 3 ans j'ai souhaité également
rencontrer d'autres thérapeutes
intéressés à cette par cette question là
et nous avons notamment cofondé le
réseau des professionnels de
l'accompagnement face à l'urgence
écologique notamment avec Charline
Schmerber qui est très active sur ce
sujetl également et h je suis également
membre du groupe d'intérêt et d'études
de l'Association française de thérapie
cognitive et comportementale euh donc si
je donne ces informationsl un c'est pour
dire que surtout je pourrais vous donner
des retours au niveau de mon retour
terrain puisqueaujourd'hui j'ai une file
active on va dire d'un/ers de mes
patient sur la question des écoancieux
et comme le disait tout à l'heure
professeur pelissolo c'est bien
évidemment dû à quelque chose d'un
billet de sélection puisque je suis
labelliser entre guillemets é
psychothérapeute écosensible euh mais
voilà euh je peux aussi donner un peu la
la voix porter la voix d'autres
thérapeutes terrain du fait de cette de
ce de ce réseau des accompagnants face à
l'urg écologique et également de de ce
groupe d'intérêt d'étude et par ailleurs
un autre élément qui me semble
intéressant qu'on va dont on va parler
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la
sensibilisation je suis également
formatrice à l'accompagnement des
émotions pour les personnes qui se
forment aux outils de sensibilisation
comme notamment la fresque du climat qui
est un outil de sensibilisation sur la
question l'écologique voilà et donc
c'est comment est-ce que on va donner
ces informations là mais en même temps
s'assurer qu'il y a un accompagnement
émotionnel pour que ça ne vienne pas
effondrer les personnes parce que ça
peut des fois donner cet élément-l donc
mon regard sur la question de
l'écoanxiété euh suite à un petit peu du
quo au retour terrain déjà tout d'abord
c'est vraiment important pour moi de de
pointer le fait que ce n'est pas une
maladie euh comme ça a déjà été cité ici
au niveau de la la de mes collègues mais
aussi c'est c'est vraiment soutenu au
niveau de par exemple de l'Association
américaine de psychologie la pas aussi
le le climate psychology alliance donc
l'alliance climatique psychologique qui
est notamment créée en Angleterre et
vraiment il poent pour eux c'est
vraiment important de pointer le fait
que aujourd'hui on ne peut pas parler
d'une maladie ou d'une pathologie sur ce
sur la question de
l'écoanxiété euh à titre un petit peu
comparatif une des choses que j'aime
bien dire c'est un peu comme si une
personne vivait un deuil elle la enfin
c'est indéniable qu'elle va
souffrir la question de l'écoanxiété
sera un peu SIM c'est-à-dire que la
souffrance est indéniable à partir du
moment où il y a une prise de conscience
de la situation c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose de de douloureux à la perspective
un petit peu de de la situation et la
mitation actuelle qui nous attendent
mais on ne peut pas dire que c'est
pathologique lorsqu'on souffre un deuil
par contre il est possible parfois de
vivre un deuil pathologique c'est-à-dire
que ça va se transformer il va y avoir
chez certaines personnes quelque chose
qui va faire que cet état là ne va
devenir invalidant ou va générer une
paralysie ou en tout cas son
fonctionnement ne va pu être possible je
je prends un petit peu ce parallèle
parce que c'est également une façon de
dire et ce n'est pas parce que ce n'est
pas une pathologie qu'on ne peut pas
l'écouter en en séance c'est-à-dire que
on peut aussi souffrir d'écoanxiété sans
que ça soit forcément pathologique mais
demander quand même à être reçu et
écouter sur ce sujet-là comme on peut
être reçu sur une question d'un deuil
voilà
ensuite l'autre élément qui me semble
important par rapport à la question de
l'écoanxiété déjà c'est que c'est un
terme que moi je trouve personnellement
et d'autres collègues aussi assez
malheureux c'est un terme qui ne vient
pas d'une réflexion clinique d'étude des
symptômes et du coup d'une réflexion sur
comment est-ce qu'on va nommer cette
souffrance là c'est pour ça que je nomme
depuis tout à l'heure la notion de
souffrance de manière générale face à
l'urgence écologique parce qu'en fait
comme le disait d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure professeur pilou nous sommes pas
face uniquement à une plainte en terme
d'anxiété mais il y a énormément il y a
une palette importante d'émotion souvent
on parle d'coémotion et et et donc du
coup c'est c'est un terme assez
malheureux parce que du coup on va se
centrer sur la notion uniquement d'un de
d'anxiété et d'ailleurs on va l'associer
très rapidement à un notion de trouble
anxieux alors que ce n'est pas forc ça
ne va pas forcément devenir un trouble
anxieux ça peut devenir plein d'autres
choses il y a Charline schmerberg
notamment qui utilise le terme de de
écoanxiété systémique pour pointer le
fait que certes les les personnes se
plaignent de d'une inquétude par rapport
au réchauffement climatique et aux
conséquences mais elles vont ell elles
vont avoir aussi donc d'une part la
palette d'émotion qui va être très large
mais également aussi des inquiétudes qui
vont aller au-delà de la question du
réchauffement climatique comme par
exemple donc au niveau donc c'est une
étude qualitative mais quand même elle a
porté sur 1066 personnes en France les
personnes se plaignaient exprimaient
vraiment en top on va dire top 3 des de
l'anxiété des raisons de l'anxiété
c'était la perte de la biodiversité
l'inquiétude en terme de de P urie d'eau
et également ensuite en TR en troisème
point la question du réchauffement
climatique donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question d'avoir peur on va dire d'un
point de vue de la météo qui fasse chaud
il y avait aussi des une dimension très
importante qui était ce n'est pas juste
les conséquences on va dire climatiques
mais c'est aussi sur tous les autres
sphères de la
vie qui qui nous qui nous concerne et là
lorsqu'on leur demande un petit peu quel
est le leur le risque qui voit derrière
un peu cette situation c'est en top 1
c'est la guerre ensuite il y a la
question des pénuries donc je disais
pénurie d'eau pénurie alimentaire euh
c'est aussi la la perspective de
violence qu'on se Batt puisque on se
retrouve dans des situations avec moins
de ressources et une inquiétude comme ça
de de situation d'une violence qui
pourrait augmenter
euh la peur aussi de de de crise
économique de crash boursi euh des
risques sanitaire donc on voit que c'est
une inquiétude qui est beaucoup plus
large euh voilà
un autre élément donc qui me semblait
important de de pointer
c'était parce que c'est vrai que ça ça
touche quand même ça peut toucher tout
le monde mais c'est vrai que ça touche
quand même beaucoup les jeunes
et les études donc on a cité tout à
l'heure l'étude du LAN de 2021 pote
qu'il a une corrélation quand même très
forte entre la perception qu'on les
jeunes donc parce que c'est une étude
qui a été fait sur les jeunes la
perception qu'ont les jeunes
sur les actions
les actions politiques qui sont faites
par rapport à à la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et lescoiniété
c'est-à-dire plus il sent qu'il y a une
inaction ou en tout cas des actions qui
ne sont pas à la hauteur plus
l'écoanxiété est forte et cette
corrélation on la retrouve dans d'autres
études notamment aussi une étude qui a
été fait par la Fondation jores avec
vraiment le le c'est-à-dire
que la souffrance n'est pas juste
l'inquiétude à un niveau individuel mais
c'est l'expression d'une d'une
difficulté de de d'un sentiment un peu
d'abandon d'une génération par rapport à
une autre ou en tout cas du sentiment
que on est pas entendu quand je dis on
c'est c'est pas que les jeunes se
sentent pas entendus sur ces questions
là et que du coup il y aurait comme un
sentiment de de presque de violence de
voir que la vie continue telle qu'elle
est que tout voilà alors que il y aurait
des des actions majeures à entreprendre
et et je cite ici une personne qui me
semble extrêmement importante qui aurait
été à mon avis très intéressante dans
cette table ronde mais qui est
malheureusement pas en France il s'agit
de l'éia Benoît c'est une pédopsychiatre
française mais qui est aux États-Unis
qui travaille à l'université de yel et
qui a fait une étude sur cette
questionlà sur les jeunes de 8 à pardon
de 7 à 18 ans et euh elle a également
mis en évidence un petit peu ce que je
pointais c'est-à-dire que la souffrance
n'est pas juste une souffrance par
rapport à la question du réchauffement
climatique mais bien de la réponse de la
société et des gouvernements ou des
entreprises par rapport à ces enjeux-là
et que un des des leviers majeurs on va
dire de soulagement ou d'apaisement de
cette inquiétude ou même de la
souffrance de manière générale c'est de
sentir que ses parents parlent du sujet
agissent sur cette question c'est-à-dire
sentir la génération du dessus faire
quelque chose et c'est un des facteurs
de de protection les plus importants
pour ces jeuneslà voilà h enfin juste
rapidement pour la question des réponses
publiques mais je pense qu'on pourra
prendre le temps après d'en parler un
petit peu plus c'était donc de ce
dernier point que je viens de dire
c'està-dire que un ça me semble
important que la réponse soit une
réponse sur deux points c'est-à-dire un
effectivement une réponse d'écoute
vraiment importante puisqueaujourd'hui
comme je pointais tout à l'heure j'ai dû
aller les chercher pour écouter beaucoup
de thérapeutes disent mais moi j'entends
pas ce sujet alors qu'on voit des
chiffres énormes j'entends pas ce sujet
en cabinet et ça c'est
euh il y a un retour vraiment d'une
défiance ou d'une méfiance des lieux
thérapeutiques comme espace pour pouvoir
être écouté parce qu'il y a
effectivement quelque chose un peu de
sentiment que les les thérapeutes ne
sont pas écosensibilisés ou en tout cas
ne sont pas formés à la question
euh il y a la question de de mais à côté
il est vraiment important de peut-être
communiquer sur ce qui se fait et donner
un sentiment un peu de de de
compétenence et de que justement les
pouvoirs publics agissent par ailleurs
également je voulais rappeler qu'il
existe aujourd'hui une proposition des
premiers secours en santé mentale qui
s'est basé notamment sur un programme
qui a été créé en Australie qui est
vraiment très intéressant et très
pertinent parce que ça peut permettre du
fait qu'on est en train de parler quand
même de quelque chose qui prend beaucoup
d'ampleur que on forme notamment les
jeunes à s'accompagner ou en tout cas
les adultes aussi accompagner les jeunes
déjà dans des premier temps d'écoute en
terme de santé mentale et on pourrait
rajouter dans ce programme là les enjeux
desécoanxiété justement donc ça c'est
une
proposition et
ensuite faire attention au niveau des
campagnes de sensibilisation
de transmettre des informations mais de
former les
sensibilisateurs qui qui a une formation
non seulement on va dire au chiffres
mais aussi quand même à l'écoute parce
qu'on ne peut pas transmettre ce type
d'information là sans qu'il y ait quand
même une une intelligence on va dire
humaine et psychologique dans parce
qu'on peut ça peut parfois beaucoup
effondrer d'autant plus les jeunes qui
lorsqu'ils entendent ce type
d'information là disent mais qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on fasse voilà j'ai
j'ai fini merci désolé pour la
longueur bonjour à tous donc Pierre-Éric
Suter merci de m'avoir invité à cette
table ronde alors je suis psychologue du
travail depuis une trentaine d'années
mais je suis aussi psychologue clinicien
et psychothérapeute enseignant chercheur
euh et je préside aussi une association
qui s'appelle la maison des échanxieux
euh je dirige l'Observatoire de
l'éco-anxiété qui est le premier
observatoire qui permet de prendre la
mesure du niveau d'écoanxiété en France
avec une équipe de de chercheurs
professeurs d'universit unité euh et euh
je suis retourné faire des études au
knam parce qu'il était nécessaire que je
continue de creuser ce sillon que j'ai
initié en 2016 puisque je ne suis pas
venu à l'cxété c'est l'cxété qui est
venue à moi et vous allez le voir comme
sans doute monsieur mandellini elle va
venir de plus en plus souvent à vous au
travers de de de de vos proches ou de
vos ou des citoyens euh j'en veux pour
preuve un certain nombre de de
d'expériences que je vais vous partager
et notamment d'abord ma première
patiente celle que j'appelle ma patiente
zéro qui venu me voir dans mon cabinet
de psychothérapeute en 2016 pour un
burnout initialement et puis qui m'a
parlé DESCO anxiété alors je ne savais
pas ce que c'était hein j'étais
totalement ignorant du sujet et j'ai été
voir comme tout praticien qui sonore le
le Sim le classement international des
maladie à l'époque c'était la version 10
et qui géré par l'OMS et qui référence
donc tous les tableaux cliniques et je
n'ai rien trouvé sur les conétés et pour
cause ça a été dit par mes maises les
intervenants qui m'ont précédé
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien de d'officiel
d'institutionnel qui permet d'encadrer
ce phénomène et donc je comme j'ai des
incointance avec la recherche par que
vous avvez déjà créé des observatoires
notamment l'Observatoire de la vie au
travail et l'Observatoire l'Observatoire
la vie au travail pardon je j'ai été
voir mes amis chercheurs et on a fait
une petite revue littérature je me suis
rendu compte que l'échxiété est un terme
connu depuis 1997 mais sans vraiment
beaucoup de recherchees jusqu' à l'or
des années 2010 et là je intéresse à la
question et je décide de parce que à
l'époque on parlait pas des conanxiété
pas tellement dans dans les médias même
pas du tout avant avant 2018 c'est à
partir de 2018 que ça explose puisque de
2018 à 2021 il y a plus 600 % de de de
référence avec anxiété et de 201 de 2018
à 2021 2021 à 2022 plus 600 % à nouveau
et je pense que ça va encore exploser
j'ai pas regardé les statistiques donc
l'éco anxiété vient à nous et notamment
via les médias et là ils sont venus
clairement d'un point de vue clinique
j'étais au chevet d'une première
patiente et conxieuse qui me dit voilà
en plus de subir l'effondrement de mon
burnout l'effondrement intérieur je dois
subir l'effondrement du monde extérieur
je la regarde je regarde par la fenêt je
dis bah non le monde il a l'air d'être
là me dit je crois que vous êtes pas au
courant de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le monde à l'extérieur vous
AZ sans doute pas les bonnes lunettes je
vais vous donner un livre à lire elle
m'a fait livre elle m'a fait lire un
livre qui s'appelle comment tout peut
s'effondrer de Pablo servine qui est un
des chefs de filles de la collapsologie
la collapsologie a beaucoup été décriée
quand bien même elle s'appuie sur des
écrits scientifiques et c'est ça qui m'a
attiré c'est ça qui m'a interpellé et
c'est pour ça qu'en 2018 j'ai créé un
observatoire qui s'appelle
l'Observatoire des vécus du collapse
pour essayer de rendre compte ce que
c'était que ce ce vécu puisque ça
semblait traumatiser les gens moi
j'étais pas traumatisé euh par cette
question-là euh un peu comme le disait
Monsieur Jean sol c'est dire bon ok une
anxiété sur une éventuel effondrement
mais il est toujours là le monde euh et
puis en me documentant et en regardant
ce qui se passait euh donc euh dans dans
ces écrits notamment ce du GC j'ai pris
la mesure en fait de de de ce qui est en
train de se passer et c'est en fait une
histoire de lunett c'est un peu comme
quand pasteur a découvert les microbes
et que tous les médecins l'ont un petit
peu regardé devant lu disont mais c'est
quoi cette histoire de microbe on va pas
se laver les mains pour faire accoucher
les femmes et donc effectivement la
mortalité infantile continuait comme
elle elle l'était à l'époque puis un
jour ils ont pris la mesure en regardant
dans l' dans le dans le le comment
s'appelle le microscope et ils ont
compris ils ont compris en fait ils
avaient pas les bonnes lunettes et en
fait les collapsologues m'ont donné
certaines lunettes pour voir cette cette
avec des exagérations hein parce qu'il y
en a certains qui sont NIST donc on
pourrait faire une sociologie de la
collapsologie qui a déjà d'ailleurs été
faite mais peu importe c'est pas le lieu
du sujet puisque moi je suis un
psychologue clinicien en plus d'être un
psychologue du travail et donc il me
fallait trouver les moyens de soigner
cette passion AC anxieuse et donc petit
à petit je me suis renseigné et petit à
petit j'ai vu que la science évoluait
et d'abord j'ai pris conscience que
l'écoanxiété ça n'était pas une maladie
comme ça a été dit euh notamment au
travers des recherches scientifiques
vous avez trois possibilités en santé
mentale la santé mentale positive d'un
côté du continuum et de l'autre côté
dans dans l'autre extrême vous avez les
psychopathologies et les les paologies
les pathologies psychiatriques et au
milieu vous avez ce qu'on appelle la
détresse psychologique c'est-à-dire un
état intermédiaire entre cette santé
mentale positive et la possibilité
d'évoluer vers une psychopathologie et
ce que disent les chercheurs je vous la
fais courte parce que j'ai pas beaucoup
de temps c'est qu'en fait la la et c'est
la définition de d'une équipe de
chercheurs newzélandais qui a retenu mon
attention que j'ai synthétisé comme je
vous l' dire c'est une détresse
psychologique face aux enjeux
environnementaux elle mérite de la
simplicité cette définition une détresse
psychologique face aux enjeux
environnementaux parce qu'elle raconte
cette histoire de dégradation de l'état
mental j'étais en santé mentale positive
et tout à coup je me prends en pleine
figure en pleine poire les informations
de l'effondrement du monde ou on peut on
peut pour pour les détailler dans dans
l'échange tout à l'heure parce qu'ils
sont actuels par exemple vous avez
l'effondrement la biodiversité
aujourd'hui il y a 1 million d'espèces
sur les 11 millions répertorés qui sont
menacé d'extinction massiv pour prendre
un exemple exemple euh et euh donc cet
état de de de de détresse psychologique
il est lié à la prise d'information de
tous ces effondrements que vivent les
patients dans leur fort intérieur dans
leur
euh dans leur rapport au monde voilà et
donc il y a quelque chose d'existentiel
qui se passe très rapidement c'est que
il se projette dans l'avenir en se
disant mais si on va comme ça vers
l'effondrement d'un certain nombre de de
choses notamment des espèces vivantes
des règlements climatiques si les
sécheresses continuent à venir il va y
avoir moins d'eau et cetera et cetera on
va moins bien manger moins bien boire
moins bien respirer moins bien vivre et
le covid est venu valider en partie
cette thèse là et donc il y a des
craintes existentielles et c'est pour ça
que les enfants s'inquiètent pour leur
avenir parce que ici dans cette salle je
crois qu'il y en a pas beaucoup et notre
avenir il est plutôt derrière nous que
devant nous pour les les les les les
bibounur que nous sommes mais eux ils
ont leur avenir qui est devant eux et
donc ils s'inquiètent du monde qu'on va
leur laisser et c'est ce qui se passe on
pourrait dire essentiellement chez les
enfants mais moi j'ai constaté
empiriquement que ma patientelle était
composée autant de jeunes que d'adultes
que de de de quin cas enfin de vingir
trir quir et qu'un cas et j'ai voulu en
avoir le CNET et donc j'ai créé cet
observatoire l'observatoire de
l'écoanxiété avec des chercheurs sur la
base des travaux de recherche de HOG et
alii donc l'équipe d'australo australo
néozélandaise qui a le mérite de
proposer une définition simple mais
aussi un référentiel qui m'a permis de
d'évaluer lescoanxiétés un référentiel
donc de de symptômes cliniques qui me
permet toujours au quotidien de de
valider cette écété surtout ils l'ont
assorti d'un outil diagnostique que nous
avons transposé euh au travail d'une
étude de recherche mais on a été doublé
par une équipe lilloise qui s'appelle
enfin qui sont les travaux de maté qui a
donc transposer cette échelle tout
récemment donc on a maintenant un outil
de diagnosticque qui est viable fiable
pardon validé scientifiquement et qui
permet des mesures decoanxiété
simplement aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'étalonnage puisque les conanxiétés
c'est un peu comme la fièvre
c'est-à-dire que comme toute détresse
psychologique elle est plus ou moins
intense et chronique et c'est quand elle
s'intensifie qu'elle se chronicise
qu'elle devient une psychopathologie que
là nos amis psychiatres ont besoin de de
mettre tout en œuvre pour traiter euh
les patients que nous les psychologues
ne pouvons plus traiter euh et ce qui
est intéressant dans l'outil de HOG et
Alice c'est qu'on a donc une possibilité
de mesurer cette cette échoanxiété au
travers de d'un tableau clinique qui est
pas exhaustif comme puisque la la
science progresse par fascification
successive mais qui permet de
d'identifier de faire un diagnostic
différentiel des écoanxieux parce que
c'est pas parce que je dis que je suis
écoanxieux que je suis vraiment hein
c'est pour ça que moi les études qui se
basent sur des sondages je m'en méfie
beaucoup et même les études
scientifiques celle qui a été nommée
notamment de Hickman qui qui est la
faculté de B de BF en Angleterre moi
elle me gênait parce que d'abord elle se
centralisait seulement sur les jeunes et
pas sur l'ensemble de la population et
elle elle elle faisait plutôt état d'un
sondage c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez
votre LC c'estd que l'équipe de HOG et
Alidi elle de HOG et Ali elle propose un
outil de diagnostique c'està-dire dire
de de d'auscultation si j'ose dire de la
de du mental des individus et il manque
encore aujourd'hui une une une un
étalonnage qui permet de classifier on a
proposé dans une publication
scientifique intermédiaire une première
proposition d'étalonnage qui permet de
dire je suis faiblement écoancieux à
très fortement
écoanxeux et évidemment plus on est
fortement écoanceux plus on se rapproche
d'une problématique de de
psychopathologie on peut ça menace notre
santé c'est là où les conté menace notre
santé mentale et où l'écoancieux peut
basculer euh dans un problème de santé
mentale voilà j'ai été assailli par les
écoanxieux c'est devenu principalement
ma patientelle alors comme comme le
disait le docteur pellissolo je deviens
juger parti parce que à force de savoir
que je suis un expert lesanxiété les
gens viennent de me voir parce que un
mes patients un patient sur deux de mes
patients m'a dit j'ai été voir un de vos
confrères ils ont rien compris ce que je
leur disais ils ont revécu ce que
j'avais vécu moi avec ma ma patiente ma
première patiente c'estd que on regarde
par la fenêtre et puis on comprend pas
ce que c'est que les fond viment du
monde tant qu'on a pas pris la mesure
avec des documents scientifiques de la
documentation scientifique c'est les
scientifiques qui nous le disent depuis
50 ans une des toutes premières études
elle date de 1972 on parle déjà de ces
problèmes et quand on regarde un peu
plus profondément même dans les médias
américains dès les années 50 on parlait
déjà du gaz des gaz à effet de serre et
c'est donc quelque chose qu'on a négligé
qui aujourd'hui nous revient comme un
boomrang dans la figure notamment par
des porte-paroles que sont les
écoancieux et pour moi les écoancieux
c'est pas des personnes pathologiques
c'est dit par les scientifiques et par
mes prédécesseurs sont des gens qui
s'inquiètent pour l'avenir et même pour
le présent et je je dirais même que
c'est des les éch-ambassadeurs de la
transition écologique c'estàd que ce
sont des gens qui ont une clairevoyance
une éco clairevyance sur ce qu'il
faudrait changer dans le monde pour
qu'il aille mieux et pour éviter qu'il
se dégrade pour continuer à bien manger
bien boire bien respirer et bien vivre
je vous remercie pour votre
écoute merci dans mon propos introductif
j'ais cité deux mots lucidité espérance
et je pense qu'on a tous effectivement
un rôle à jouer que ce soit les médias
ou les ou les élus sur les sujets il y a
quelqu qu demandes de prise de parole
Ron pour Jean toi tu as
Corine est-ce qu'il y a d'autres Mar
faire par série trois questions
peut-être donc Ren Corine et puis Mara
puis ensuite laence
r oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour l'organisation de cette table ronde
parce que ça nous permet de mettre sur
la table un sujet qu'on n
jamais cherché à
approfondir moi j'ai bien entendu je
crois que c'est le point quand même clé
c'est l'coanxité départ n'est pas une
pathologie en fait c'est un rapport au
monde c'est une lecture du monde je
crois que c'est important quand même
d'abord de dire même si après ça peut
alimenter des névroses boire des
névroses préexistantes enfin là je sors
de mon propre domaine de compétenence
assez rapidement du coup moi ma question
c'est plutôt d'essayer
d'analyser avant la partie
purement où ça devient une pathologie
mais ça peut devenir une pathologie mais
peut-être pas très différente finalement
des autres pathologies il faudrait
regarder compris dans l'histoire avant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale quelles
étaient les pathologies d'anxiété enfin
il y a d'autres périodes certainement ou
même la guerde d'Algérie enfin voir les
les les les comment comment les périodes
d'anxiété lié au contexte politique euh
cré derrière de la pathologie donc c'est
pas c'est pas nouveau mais euh
effectivement moi je il me semble
intéressant alors c'est un peu à la
limite de vos propres compétences mais
on aurait besoin peut-être d'analyser
plus alors c'est ça tient du sondage et
de l'étude quantitative donc c'est
évidemment pas si simple quelles sont
les conséquences en termes
comportementaux de cette montée de
l'écoonxiété euh y compris en terme
sociétaux économique euh il y a il y a
un exemple que vous avez finalement peu
cité mais qui semble quand même assez
central aujourd'hui euh qui est la
baisse de natalité parce que ça on
l'entend tous on a beau être d'une
génération de boomurs on on voit bien
dans les discussions avec les jeunes euh
comment cet écho anxiété se traduit par
une baisse euh du nombre d'enfants ce
qui veut dire aussi et c'est extrêmement
intéressant qu'on en discute ici au
Sénat c'est que à chaque fois que la
société a le sentiment d'un retour en
arrière sur les grandes luttes
environnementales pour des raisons
généralement immédiates qui peuvent
s'entendre mais qui sont immédiates
benah ça veut dire que derrière on perd
de la natatalité on perd des enfants on
change des comportements qui vont contre
le modèle économique de ceux qui ont
justement cherché à retarder les efforts
à
faire si vous trouvez un lien avec
l'actualité c'est votre responsabilité à
tous et à chacun mais cette question moi
me semble assez centrale c'est-à-dire de
de voir aujourd'hui au-delà de de du
moment où ça devient une pathologie
effectivement quels sont les les
changements comportementaux les
principes
et dont nous on a évidemment en tant que
législateur
derrière intégré donc ça c'est pour moi
une question assez essentiel l'autre
c'est effectivement je pense que la
collapsologie et les études du GC ne
sont pas de même
nature c'est important qu' je crois
qu'on est d'accord notamment la place
donnée par les collapsologues à à la
crise énergétique oui et n'est pas du
tout dans dans ce que le G raconte qui a
une vraie différence mais comment la
collapsologie impacte effectivement
lecoanxiété ça me semble une autre
question importante merci merci
Corine merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames messieurs pour vos
interventions deux petites deux petites
questions dans la mesure où vous nous
avez expliqué donc que lescoanxiété
n'était pas une maladie n'était pas une
pathologie en quoi notre système de
santé pourrait contribuer à apporter euh
des réponses à cette détresse
psychologique pour reprendre vos termes
et puis une autre question très courte
euh vous nous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
monsieur Suter euh l'écoanxiété vient à
nous notamment par les médias
euh en quoi
euh en en en en en terme de enfin quel
est quel est votre pardon quelle est
votre appréciation par rapport à cette
information qui est donnée en continu
sur des chaînes d'information 2424 et
qui visiblement aggrave l'co anxiété je
remercie merci présidente de me passer
la parole j'avais en fait plusieurs
questions elles ont été un petit peu
abordées aussi parce que il me semble
que l'anxiété d'une de nos jeunesses ça
a déjà existé par le passé je pense au
courant IPI par exemple qui est un
courant qui qui est derrière nous il y
avait le sujet de la guerre l'inquiétude
qui que une forme de manifestation
d'anxiété d'une certaine jeunesse
aujourd'hui tous les quatre et je vous
remercie hein parce que ça nous éclaire
sur un un phénomène effectivement dont
on entend parler de plus en plus vous
nous dites on on vous êtes des
thérapeutes des clinicien vous
accueillez vous parlez beaucoup de
jeunes que vous accueillez dans le cadre
de vos de vos activités avec parfois des
diagnostics que vous-même posez j'avais
envie une première question est-ce que
vous vous êtes et conanxieux déjà et
est-ce que votre propre positionnement
par rapport à ce phénomène n'influence
pas votre propre thérapie excusez-moi je
je peux vous paraître un peu
provocatrice d'autant plus que je crois
que c'est professeur pelissolo qui
disait lorsque je sens qu'ils ont besoin
queon leur dise quoi faire je les
oriente vers des éventuellement un
militantisme écologique et cetera mais
euh dans le fond si quelqu'un vient pour
maltraitance vous ne lui conseillez pas
de mettre des gants de boxe me
semble-t-il
donc je voulais connaître un petit peu
aussi votre positionnement j'ai presque
envie de dire pardon de le dire comme ça
éthique par rapport à cet échoanxiété
parce que nous sommes législateurs donc
ça rejoint aussi un peu la question très
bien mais on fait quoi en fait
concrètement avec les constats que vous
faites dans votre propre pratique
professionnelle je vous
remercie VO je vous laisse répondre je
sais pas qui répond enfin certains
d'entre vous ont été sollicités
directement
et bien je me lance en
premier du coup déjà par rapport à la
question de l'écoanxiété n'est pas une
pathologie psychiatrique elle ne l'est
pas parce queon ne la connaît pas encore
suffisamment c'est-à-dire que moi je
suis à peu près persuadée que on va
finir par avoir des critères
diagnostiques il y a des échelles qui
ont été créées pour pouvoir authentifier
quels sont les symptômes qui sont
présents oui non et effectivement ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui c'est et un
étalonnage de ces échelles pour savoir à
partir de quand on dit que il y a un
trouble ou pas de trouble
donc parce que il y a des personnes
enfin en fait ce qui ce qui définit un
trouble psychiatrique c'est le fait que
ça ait un impact sur le quotidien des
personnes et que ça les empêche de
fonctionner comme il souhaiteraiit le
faire c'est finalement la pathologie
psychiatrique elle est toujours défini
par ses conséquences sur le
fonctionnement au quotidien dans la
grande majorité des cas et donc je
effectivement certainement que pour
certaines personnes ça va être du
registre de la préoccupation et
certainement d'une préoccupation qui est
plutôt d'un registre politique et qui ne
va pas entraîner de souffrance ou pas
sous une forme qui soit invalidante mais
pour d'autres personnes et bien ça va
euh soit être un facteur précipitant
vers d'autres troubles psychiatriques
qui sont déjà connus tels que des
dépressions des troubles anxieux c'est
ça on l'a déjà évoqué soit euh et c'est
la question qui reste un peu en suspens
là en terme de de connaissance
scientifique c'est est-ce que
l'écoanxiété en elle-même est un
sous-type de trouble psychiatrique parmi
ceux qui sont déjà connus et déjà
caractérisés parce que pour certaines
personnes il y a une souffrance qui est
invalidante donc du coup bon dire que
c'est pas du tout une pathologie
psychiatrique je pense que à ce jour on
peut pas le
faire la deuxième partie c'est que
effectivement nous en tant que donc moi
je parle en tant que que psychiatre et
c'était dans la discussion de mon de mon
mémoire de fin d'étude c'est que
effectivement on a une place de de
thérapeute et c'est qu'on ne peut pas
répondre à toutes les questions qui sont
posées par lesécoanxiété c'est-à-dire
que la position que nous on peut prendre
en tant que thérapeute c'est accueillir
la souffrance et proposer des solutions
par rapport au traitement de cette
anxiété ou de cette détresse
psychologique effectivement en tant que
positionnement éthique c'est pas notre
place
de d'avoir une opinion pour nos patients
sur qu'est-ce qu'il devraiit mettre en
œuvre ou faire concrètement dans un
positionnement militant ou autre enfin
et c'est pas c'est pas tellement ça le
sens de des interventions qui sont
proposées dans les papiers qui le
proposent euh c'est plutôt de dire euh
que enin c'est plutôt dans à l'inverse
en fait c'est-à-dire les patients qui
souffrent
d'écoanxiété parmi ceux qui s'expriment
à ce sujet ont rapporter que par le fait
d'essayer de mettre en cohérence leurs
actions avec leurs convictions ressent
une diminution de l'inquiétude et de
cette incohérence et donc ressent un
effet bénéfique sur leur santé mentale
voilà mais c'est pas à nous de leur dire
de faire je ne sais pas quoi d'aller
s'engager ou pas enfin et c'est pas ça
le sens de de ce qu'on de enfin de ce
que les thérapeutes font à leur actuelle
eu parce que effectivement il y a une il
y a une cission assez importante à faire
entre B notre rôle de de psychiatre et
de psychologue et de thérapeute et notre
positionnement en tant que personne
citoyen dans la société hein donc euh
donc voilà pour pour ce
point sur les autres questions qui veut
répondre ouais je peux dire un mot on
ESS de reprendre dans l'ordre mais c'est
ça c'est vraiment toujours un peu la un
petit peu la même problématique qu'on
aborde depuis le début qui est ce qui
est normal ce qui serait pas normal ou
ce qui serait excessif parce que pour
répondre déjà à votre première question
les comportements il y a quand même
quelques petites études un peu
scientifiques psychologie sociale ou
autre qui essaent de comprendre
effectivement est-ce que les personnes
qui se déclarent avec cette anxiété
finalement changent leur comportement en
fonction de ça de de leur inquiétude ou
pas avec l'idée que on part du principe
que il y a une problématique écologique
il faut adapter ses comportements je
pense que là-dessus il y a pas de débat
de fond enfin en tout cas en majorité et
et donc que par exemple est-ce que c'est
est-ce que le fait d'être anxieux promut
ou pas enfin aide à avoir des
comportements plus proenvironnementaux
on va dire faire attention à ce qu'on
mange faire attention comment on se
déplace enfin des choses comme ça et
selon les les études montrent qu'en gros
il y a toujours les deux il y a des gens
que ça va aider pour lesquels il y a
plus de comportement enfin pour lesquels
il y a une corrélation avec des
comportements proenvironnementaux et
puis d'autres où c'est plutôt l'inverse
il y a un effet de repli il a un effet
de de pourrait dire de sidération c'est
exactement l'effet de l'anxiété dans
tous les cas l'anxiété normalement
pousse à agir pour se protéger en gr
avoir peur c'est juste éviter le danger
quand on peut et donc pour certains
c'est c'est malheureusement il y a il y
a un cap un peu excessif dans la
sidération dans le la perte de de
liberté d'action et donc pour certains
on voit que ça ça donne plutôt des
comportements alors par exemple le
renoncement à la à la parentalité on
peut l'interpréter de 1000 façons c'est
c'est très intime comme décision mais on
peut on peut le considérer comme quelque
chose où il y a un forme de renoncement
une forme de renoncement à la
transmission qui qui serait là vraiment
le pire de ce qui pourrait arriver en
tout cas à l'espèce humaine par
définition euh mais c'est un peu
l'extrême du spectre il y a heureusement
d'autres gens qui sont qui vont pas
jusque là en tout cas qui vont pas
forcément être dans dans les faits dans
cette démarche mais qui sont plutôt dans
encore une fois de repli et de
souffrance donc c'est ça que qu'on
essaie de démêler entre les l'anxiété on
va dire positive parce qu'on peut
considérer que c'est le cas s'inquiéter
pour alors moi je fais toujours
parallèle avec l'hypocondrie on peut
s'inquiéter pour sa santé c'est bien
c'est nécessaire de surveiller de pas
faire n'importe quoi avec sa santé par
contre quand on est obsédé par sa santé
qu'on arrive plus à s'empêcher à de se
surveiller d'aller consulter à tout ce
qu'on appelle l'hypocondrie il a tous
les degrés et ça peut être franchement
invalidant donc l'écoanxiété je pense
qu'il y a les mêmes la même graduation
entre quelque chose de plutôt positif on
peut dire sur le principe et puis une
écoanxiété on va dire pathologique et
donc enfin qui qui devient pathologique
c'est vrai qu'on on tourne autour du Pô
à depis le début en gros il il y a deux
il y a deux il y a deux niveaux et le
niveau de décompensation en gros c'est
celui sur lequel on intervient et quand
vous posiez la question
madame sur les le système de santé B je
crois que c'est comme dans les autres
problématiques il faut que on essaie
d'intervenir avant que ça décompense il
vaut mieux prévenir que guérir et donc
par l'information qu'on a évoqué par la
formation que les que les professionnels
puissent en parler moi je trouve que ce
que évoquait manuel Sant Marina sur les
premiers secours santé mental c'est en
effet très pertinent parce que ça
s'adresse à tout le monde que chacun
puisse apporter sa pierre à ses même à
ses amis ou avec des personnes à qui on
évolue pour que ça soit connu et qu'on
dise bah là on a l'impression son
quelque chose qui qui a besoin d'être un
petit peu pris en compte qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour préserver ma santé
mentale et c'est ça veut pas dire aller
voir un psychiatre he forcément ça peut
être bah je me repose un peu je je me
déconnecte parce qu'effectivement la
question sur les flots d'information
alors c'est pas qu'on est qu'il faut
être contre les informations quand il
arrive des catastrophes climatiques on
va pas dire je ferme les yeux je veux
pas le savoir alors évidemment les
chaînes d'information c'est un peu trop
récurrent et et spectaculaire mais le
fait est que il y a les deux niveaux il
faut informé mais pas être inondé donc
clairement les conseils qu'on donne
qu'on donne à niveau préventif là c'est
des moments de déconnexion par exemple
on voit beaucoup de de vrais
professionnels du climat ceux qui sont
chercheurs ceux qui sont dans
climatologue notamment ils sont inondés
ça en général parce que ils ont une
fibre personnelle le jour et la nuit
enfin c'est leur c'est leur engagement
et donc dans ce cas-là on va pas leur
dire mais laissez tomber ça n'a aucune
importance on va juste essayer de leur
dire comme on fait toute gestion du
stress faites dépuse prenez le temps de
respirer parce queil faut vous préserver
vous aussi donc c'est ça la démarche
vraiment et et les professionnels
peuvent accompagner ça si possible le
plus tôt possible avant que ça
décompense et quand c'est décompensé bah
on a nos outils et pour répondre donc à
la dernière question l'engagement alors
personnel personnellement vous avez tout
à fait raison de poser la question moi
je peux le dire clairement je je pense
être écho anxieux positif c'est-à-dire
que j'en tiens compte dans mon mode de
vie j'essaie de d'y contribuer j'ai la
chance et voilà c'est comme ça j'y peux
rien c'est d'être assez protégé je pense
contre la décompensation parce que je je
pense pas en souffrir au sens de des
répercussion qu'on voit chez les malades
voilà mais c'est c'est ça vraiment qu'on
qu'on peut définir et c'est donc c'est
cette préoccupation là qui qui qui m'a
fait aussi m'intéresser au sujet et donc
notre but j'ai je me suis mal exprimé
tout à l'heure évidemment le but c'est
pas de de faire des prescriptions de de
comportement pas du tout c'est de c'est
de laisser les personnes
retrouver leur liberté d'action et le
plus souvent c'est elles qui souhait
s'engager c'estàd que quand on a cette
fibre là certains se disent bah il faut
essayer de changer les choses donc c'est
c'est pas que militant parce que les
militants qu'on voit les plus
spectaculaires c'est une chose mais
c'est aussi bah qu'est-ce que je fais
pour améliorer la biodiversité autour de
chez moi promouvoir là aussi des des
modes de vie plus adaptés c'est là qu'on
voit des personnes changer parfois de
lieux d'habitation de travail parce que
elles ont réfléchi autrement à leur vie
et se sentent comme ça en accord avec
elles-même et retrouve un apaisement en
gros se déculpabilise parce que dans une
grosse partie de la souffrance
écoanxieuse c'est quand même une forte
de d'hyper responsabilité comme si
chacun devait porter sur ses épaules le
poids de des catastrophes à venir et
donc relativiser mais se sentir utile à
quelque chose et pas uniquement passif
parce que c'est la passivité qui crée le
plus souvent la la détresse
oui merci euh donc toujours aussi
d'accord avec mes collègues je je veux
juste répondre aussi à la question sur
les conséquences en terme de
comportement de la question deécoanxiété
ce que je peux dire c'est un petit peu
un retour sur ce que m'ont dit les me
rapportte les patients donc
effectivement il y a la question de la
natalité qui vient très fréquemment il y
a aussi du coup on on parlait tout à
l'heure la question du rapport au
travail il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
sont
très disons la question du rapport au
travail peut arriver dans plein plein de
moment plein de personnes différentes
mais dans ce cas-là ça peut générer une
souffrance très forte parce que ça met
en conflit les valeurs internes avec par
fois tout d'un coup un abandon très
soudain du travail des personnes qui se
mettent en situation de précarité
d'ailleurs par rapport à ça ou aussi des
réflexions au niveau de leur lieu de vie
et donc il peut y avoir des des coups de
volant assez rapides et assez
spectaculaires je je dirais aussi en
terme de comportement je vois une
certaine défiance qui est là par rapport
à la question du système de santé vous
posiez la question tout à l'heure de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut notre système de de
santé peut faire par si ce n'est pas une
pathologie je pense effectivement que la
question de la de la prévention comme
l'a pointé tout à l'heure le professeur
pcelo est essentielle d' d'autant plus
qu'on va vers un système de santé de
plus en plus saturé et on sait combien
la prévention est nécessaire pour éviter
justement après que plus plus ça
s'aggrave et plus c'est compliqué après
accompagner donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose
d'essentiel cette histoire de prévention
sachez que la psych enfin les
psychologues cliniciens nous ce qu'on
nous demande c'est à la base notre
métier c'est sensé être de la prévention
nous ne sommes pas censés recevoir des
personnes que l'on doit guérir mais au
contraire justement qui sont dans cette
fenêtre dont parlait tout à l'heure
pierc Suter de détresse psychologique à
20 afin d'éviter qu'il rentrent en
décompensation et qu' doivent peut-être
consulter ensuite les psychiatres par
exemple pour justement prendre des
médicaments par rapport à ça ou voilà
donc ça ça me semble vraiment important
et la question de la défiance du coup on
en revient sur la proposition qu'on
pointait tout à l'heure qui était
l'importance de former des thérapeutes à
cette question là parce que et là je
vais je vais boucler avec la question de
l'éthique et de notre propre
positionnement c'est évident que enfin
c'est quelque chose de très fréquent
qu'on retrouve en tout cas dans notre
métier on s'intéresse à ce qui nous
appelle on va dire souvent d'un point de
vue personnel moi je peux dire
effectivement que je suis éco anxieuse
un peu comme le poait tout à l'heure
professeur pelissolo mais mais avec
cette idée que j'aime pas du tout ce
terme c'est-à-dire oui j'ai souffert de
la question de des enjeux écologiques
aujourd'hui je me trouve très apaisée
par rapport à cette question je me sens
on va dire aligné je mets en place des
choses par rapport à ça et c'est bien ça
ce que je souhaite en fait à mes
patients c'est-à-dire pouvoir être
aligné pouvoir être dans un
positionnement de vie dans lequel ils
sont plutôt euh justement où il y a il y
a pas de risque psychologique pour eux
c'est ça qui me semble vraiment
important et et cette question elle est
d'autant plus importante si on regarde
par exemple dans la période du covid les
soignants ont beaucoup souffert parce
que eux-mêmes c'està dire c'est dur
d'accompagner quelqu'un alors que
nous-mêmes nous vivons ça or il est
d'autant plus important de se dire que
nous soignants nous avons besoin de nous
pencher sur cette question de nous
préparer d'une certaine façon
psychologiquement à à à cette à à toute
à tous ces enjeux pour que quand
lorsqu'on entende ces questions-l on ne
soit pas complètement ébranlé parce que
c'est c'est euh je je prendrai la la
question à la ver c'est-à-dire c'est
essentiel au contraire que nous soyons
formés et que nous soyons sensibilisés à
cette question la fois que nous soyons
des personnes solides et en bonne santé
pour recevoir nos patients euh voilà
rapidement sur la question aussi de la
des impacts de du terme collapsologie et
de l'écoanxiété ou même de des flux des
médias euh il me semble effec enfin il
il a été vraiment pointé
qu'effectivement le discours uniquement
négatif est délétaire et d'ailleurs il y
a des des types d'accompagnement qui
vont proposer d'essayer de réfléchir à
des récits pas uniquement dystopiques
mais au contraire des récits de
justement d'un d'un d'un avenir souhaité
et ça a des impacts très positif
effectivement sur les patients par
rapport à ça un autre élément aussi qui
est très qui a été pointé encore une
fois dans les travaux de Laia Benois
c'est la donc c'est certes c'est de
promouvoir alors la question des
comportements c'est vrai que la thérapie
cognitive et comportementale peut
parfois euh inviter à certains
comportements pour dissoudre l'anxiété
avec l'idée que l'anxiété est soluble
dans l'action alors quand on parle
d'action c'est effectivement pas
forcément des des actions que le
thérapeute va dire vous devez faire ceci
par contre il va chercher à proposer à
la personne quelles sont les actions là
si vous êtes paralysé quelles sont les
les actions que vous souhaiteriez faire
et c'est effectivement en recherche de
mettre en contact avec les valeurs
internes de la personne et la donc
l'étude de la la Benois pointe qu'en
fait ce qui est le plus soulageant pour
les personnes c'est de rentrer dans des
actions collectives et pas uniquement
individuelles c'est-à-dire trédit déchet
prendre le vélo des choses comme ça mais
le collectif n'est pas forcément un
collectif engagé et militant voilà avec
des actions extraordinairees ça mais ça
peut être tout simplement effectivement
des rapports au niveau de son quartier
mais la notion du collectif est
importante parce qu'il y a quelque chose
du fait de je ne suis pas seul à porter
ça d'autrre que moi s'inquiète de ce
sujet et ça c'est ce que je je poais
tout à l'heure au niveau de l'importance
que ça soit porté par le sentiment que
ça soit porté par plusieurs
voilà quelques mots sur les différentes
questions effectivement l'action c'est
important on va je vais y revenir
d'abord parce que tout simplement la
science l'a montré la régulation par
l'action est plus puissante que la
régulation émotionnelle il faut réguler
les émotions négatives qui surgissent de
la prise de conscience que le monde va
va mal et s'abîme ce que vivent les écho
anxieux mais derrière si les enjeux sont
tellement énormes qu'est-ce que je peux
faire moi individuellement face à la
fonte de la banquise si pour moi c'est
important puisqueil y a une résonance
des éction avec le monde une résonance
qui peut être liée à une histoire
psychologique une patiente comme ça qui
avait une trentaine d'années me disait
quand j'avais 15 ans je plongais je
plongeais dans les calanques de près de
Marseille puisque mes grands-parents
habitaent à proximité je plongeais avec
des palmes et un masque et un tuba et je
voyais des poissons multicolor c'était
merveilleux c'était un un émerveillement
pour moi 15 ans après elle me dit je
plonge il y a plus un poisson il y a
plus un
poisson non non mais il y a plus les
poissons à calanque plastique peut-être
voilà et elle voit beaucoup de
bouteilles en plastique à la place
effectivement euh après euh c'est son
vécu je le respecte et l'éthique du
psychologue c'est de dire euh voilà
c'est votre vécu je le respecte en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que euh les
scientifiques viennent documenter des
effondrements du monde euh que vous
jugez peut-être pas vrai mais c'est la
science qui le dit c'est pas moi qui le
dit euh les patients ont écho de ces
effondrements et donc ils se trouvent
empêchés en fait d'agir qu'est-ce que je
peux faire individuellement face à la
fondme de la banquise ça c'est pas vrai
peut-être mais en tout cas c'est dit par
les scientifiques donc là banquise va
fondre qu'est-ce que je peux faire si la
banquise a un intérêt pour moi je suis
empêché dans mon action seu et donc
effectivement il y a la volonté du
recours à l'action collective donc des
recherches de de de de d'association et
cetera et cetera et on se rend compte
que même ça ça pe c'est pas suffisant et
même que les États le voudrai-il qu'il
ne le pourrai même tous ensemble ne
peuvent pas empêcher cette cette fonteel
et donc il y a une désespérance
potentielle face à à cela et moi je le
constate de plus en plus aussi dans les
entreprises ça c'est au niveau des
patients les entreprises commence à me
consulter en disant voilà on commence à
avir plein plein de personnes éconceuses
et on se rend compte qu'on les rend
éconceuses avec certaines de nos
activités ou certaines de nos pratiques
je vous donne un exemple euh une une
salariée d'une grande institution
française euh nous dit euh me dit pardon
euh voilà moi je suis préposé au voyage
et je suis horrifié du de de de de ma de
ma complicité avec le fait que je
projette des gaz à effet de serre parce
que je n'ai pas le pouvoir d'interdire
aux gens qui pourraient prendre le train
à la place de l'avion de prendre le
train alors je lui dis mais vous êtes
qui pour interdire oui mais le problème
c'est que moi ça me pose un problème
parce que je sais très bien que les gaz
à effet de serre contribuent en fait à
et je suis empêché dans mon action et
moi j'ai qu'une seule envie c'est de
quitter cet cet employeur et je voudrais
vous rappeler ce qui s'est passé en 2022
au moment où Monsieur pouyanet donc
président de total est venu dans une des
plus prestigieuxes écoles d' ingénieur
que nous avons en France qui est
Polytechnique un tiers des étudiants de
la promo sortante se sont levés il ont
tourné le dos ça veut dire qu'ils ont
pas trop envie de venir travailler dans
son entreprise donc ça veut dire que il
y a un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
sont plus ou moins impactantes sur le le
le le le les aspects climatiques et et
et environnementaux qui sont concernés
par ce problème de recrutement puis de
fidélisation d'engagement des troupes
dans les équipes et de renouvellement
des équipes dirigeantes puisque
Polytechnique c'est plutôt des futurs qu
dirigeants mais c'est à tous les niveaux
il y a une association de de de des des
grandes écoles des des des jeunes
diplômés des grandes écoles qui
s'appelle
euh défi écologique je crois j'ai oublié
le nom peu importe qui a été fourné en
2018 et qui disent il ont une charte il
dit nous ne travailleront jamais dans
une entreprise qui ne présente pas euh
euh euh des gages de respect de
l'environnement et qui fait pas du Green
wasing donc on a clairement des tas de
personnes qui se disent je ne serais pas
complice du système à part à partir du
moment il est avéré qu'il est comment
dirais-je menaçant pour l'environnement
voilà donc ça c'est clair que de plus en
plus il y a des entreprises qui en
prennent conscience et là on a on est on
est sur cet aspect de la première
question de des conséquences dans le
domaine socio-économique c'est-à-dire
que là comment on va faire tourner les
entreprises il y a des exemples très
simples he moi j'intéri au niveau des
colesbleleu cette fois-ci je
termine qui sont dans des entrepôts qui
sont en plein été à plus de 3 3 degr le
le droit de retrait leur empêche
d'arrêter de travailler ben pas de bras
pas de production voilà ça va aussi
arriver comme
ça la parole est à Laurent surossignol
et ensuite Patricia demain et
Michel Bir oui ça y est merci monsieur
le Président d'abord merci d'avoir
organisé cette réunion commune à nos
deux commissions affaires sociales et
aménagement et merci aux intervenants
euh sur leurs propos si je essaie de
retenir ce que je peux retenir de votre
propos euh les coanxiétés on est tous
d'accord pour dire que le mot est pas
bon mais comme on n a pas un d'autre on
va continuer de l'utiliser pour la
commodité de la conversation euh enfin
encore ce matin euh n'est pas une
pathologie c'est une souffrance c'est
pas non plus une phobie c'est important
aussi de le dire c'est une souffrance
euh qui peut être invalidante et aboutir
à des des compensations donc il faut
aider ceux qui souffrent les aider à
souffrir moins et accompagner ceux qui
sont passés au un stade supérieur et qui
ont sont atteints de de enfin qui qui
ont des des décompensations peut-être
quand même ça nous en tant que où est
notre place à nous la vôtre je la vois
assez bien la nôtre consiste à voter
plus de crédit pour la psychiatrie on
essaye et votre statut on essaye mais
notre place à nous en tant que
législateur moi j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir affaire à des individus jeunes
quand même le plus souvent qui sont
juste atteint si j'ose dire d'une
hyperlcidité
et ce n'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire des collègues ont évoqué tout
à l'heure il y en a auparavant oui
l'exemple qui me vient le premier à
l'esprit c'est stevenenswag voilà
atteint d'une
hyperlcidité sur l'état de
l'Europe pendant la montée du nazisme et
qui va jusqu'au suicide
parce que à un moment donné il écrit ce
qu'il voit ce qu'il sait qui va se
passer n'est pas partagé par le plus
grand nombre et donc une impression
d'immense solitude dans la lucidité du
monde comment nous on peut intervenir
aujourd'hui
euh j'ai quand même le sentiment que les
responsables politiquees ceux qui sont
crédités de décider de l'état du monde
euh ont une responsabilité peuvent
accroître ou prévenir ce sentiment d'co
anxiété quand on annonce les collègues
vont probablement vont vont sursauter
mais quand on annonce la pause dans
l'usage des pesticides la pause dans la
réduction des pesticides je prends le
Paris que à cet instant-là on accroit
lescoanxiétés des gens qui sont sens qui
qui sont affecté par par ça et
donc la manière dont nous nous
restituons
à la population et pas simplement aux
éch anxieux d'ailleurs à la aux autres
avant qu'ils le devienne à la population
la prise en compte de la réalité et qu'
ne sont pas des gens en marche du monde
qui se fer se raconterit c'est pas c'est
voilà c'est pas des ils sont pas en
collapsologie voilà ils sont c'est pas
des c'est pas des gens qui pensent que
c'est pas des dystopiques ils ont une
conscience de l'état du monde et la
solitude de ne pas partager politique
est très lourde donc j'attire notre
attention le fait que nous avons une
responsabilité dans la prévention du
développement descoanxiété parce que mon
sentiment c'est qu'on en est qu'au début
de l'histoire voilà ça ne va pas ça ne
va pas se se réduire et comme je dois
poser une question j'en pose une au
médecin et au psychologue enfin tous les
tous les soignants qui sont là est-ce
que vous avez observé une corrélation
entre l'hypersensibilité émotionnelle et
les patients que vous accompagnez en éc
ct
tria oui merci donc merci à l'ensemble
des des orateurs pour leur intervention
je vais pas reprendre tout ce qui a été
dit moi je m'interrogeris en fait sur ce
phénomène de l'écoanxiété et sur si
toutes les parties du monde étai
concerné de la même manière est-ce que
c'est pas un problème typiquement des
sociétés occidentales point
d'interrogation est-ce que vous avez
aussi vous avez parlé du du peu de
rétrospective que vous aviez sur le
sujet mais l'interrogation est-ce que
c'est un phénomène culturel est-ce que
c'est un phénomène sociétal est-ce que
toutes les parties du monde quels que
soient les régimes euh et bien les les
générations sont concernées de la même
manière je voudrais avoir une réponse si
cela est possible sur cette question et
puis dans la mesure où on pourrait
penser que c'est un phénomène peut-être
typiquement occidental euh au niveau
donc avec une incidence ou une origine
plutôt culturelle ou sociétale quelle
quelle quelles actions quelles actions
de prévention comme toute quand on je je
vois ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
entre 2018 et 2021 plus de 600 % de
personnes écho anxieuses ne serait-il
pas bon et quel serait votre avis de
pouvoir avoir des campagnes de
prévention en amont pour renforcer la
résilience par rapport aux phénomènes
environnementaux oui merci euh monsieur
le Président merci pour ce débat euh
éminemment intéressant et qui est en
phase complète avec ce que vit notre
société parce que je pense que ce serait
ni l'évidence nous sommes toutes et tous
confrontés je crois régulièrement à des
personnes qui soitent le disent
l'affirment ou d'autres qui le sont euh
finalement sans s'en rendre compte et
donc la première question que je me
posais c'était celle du périmètre de
lescouan cété est-ce que finalement vous
considérer que des gens euh euh de nos
concitoyens qui sont euh je sais pas
victimes des inondations et qui ont peur
des tion à venir ou qui ont peur des
feux comme quand on a eu des mégafeux
est-ce que elles rentent aussi dans
cette catégorie des personnes qui sans
le savoir et sans vous consulter sans
doute ont cette forme d' anxiété enfin
ce que l'on voit dans la presse
régulièrement avec des gens qui sont au
bord du du gouffre quand à imaginé ce
que pourrait être leur lendemain et puis
la deuxième le deuxième sujet c'est que
si l'on parle de de effectivement de
cette évolution de cette transition qui
est en cours cette crainte euh face à ce
changement de monde et et à l'impact en
tout cas de la prise en compte de de
l'écologie on a parlé de capsologie tout
à l'heure moi j'imais un petit peu cette
question de du lien entre échoanxiété et
chchoradicalité euh c'est-à-dire que si
on part d'une forme d'anxiété donc de
conscience écologique qui a pour premier
euh première conséquence le sentiment de
ne pas être de ne pas pouvoir agir
puisque c'est un petit peu le le le
constat qui est partagé et que
finalement ça doit aboutir sur une forme
d'action le risque c'est aussi cette
écooradicalité qui parfois dessert je
pense queon peut tout et tous être
engagés sur des actions écologiques et
vous en avez cité quelques-unes qui me
semble tout à fait effectivement
pertinente mais la question de
l'écoradicalité est-ce que c'est pas
aussi une première réponse peut-être
même pathologique à cette écho anxiété
et comment est-ce que finalement on on
l'accompagne parce que je pense que
c'est aussi source d'inquiétude de
crainte pour pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens pour nous-même d'ailleurs
qui sommt parfois directement pris à
parti face à cette
situation bon du coup on garde l'ordre
établi du coup
ok
euh du coup par rapport à la place que
pourrai prendre les responsables
politiques je pense qu'effectivement
vous avez raison dans dans le fait que
euh ce que ce qu'on en sait c'est que
quand il quand il y a euh des prise de
position des pouvoirs publics dans le
sens d'essayer d'amoindrir les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
ou essayer de les juguler enfin d'aller
dans le sens des préconisations qui ont
pu être votées lors des différentes
copes lors de des accords de Paris
notamment on voit qu'il y a euh une
diminution de l'inquiétude générale et
que au contraire un des pourvoyeurs de
l'écoanxiété c'est de voir
une
une une inaction au niveau euh global
puisque ça renforce le sentiment
d'impuissance et le sentiment d'être
tout petit face à des enjeux qui sont
vraiment immenses parce que
effectivement aucun citoyen seul ne va
pouvoir régler à lui seul la question du
dérèglement climatique euh par rapport à
la question de est-ce que c'est un
phénomène de de société effectivement
l'écoanxiété c'est quelque chose qui est
plutôt euh décrit dans euh le nord dans
les pays du Nord économiques on va dire
que nous on a les moyens d'être inquiet
pour ce qui est à venir parce qu'on est
encore relativement et je dis bien
relativement protégé des effets directs
et indirects du du dérèglement
climatique dans les pays du Sud donc
Hémisphère Sud euh mais aussi en
Australie qui fait partie du Nord
économique pourtant mais qui est dans
une zone géographique qui en fait et euh
dramatiquement touché par le dérèglement
climatique que ce soit euh par les feux
de forêt par la sécheresse euh et par
d'autres conditions climatiques extrêmes
en fait dans ces dans ces pays-là ce
qu'on voit c'est la prévalence des
décompensation psychiatrique qui sont en
lien avec la confrontation à ces euh à
ces conséquences directes sur notre
territoire il y a un peu les deux
c'est-à-dire que il va y avoir les
personnes qui ont été confrontées à des
événements climatique extrême type
tornade inondation glissement de terrain
et j'en passe qui vont présenter les
conséquences qu'on connaît qui sont
plutôt bien documentées sur le plan
psychiatrique qui vont être plutôt du
registre du trauma qui vont être du
registre de de troubles anxieux donc
cette fois-ci qui sont pas des troubles
anxieux projectifs vers l'avenir mais
des troubles anxieux de cet arrivé et
maintenant j'ai peur que ça arrive à
nouveau et comment je gère ma vie à
partir de ce moment-là qui vont avoir
des problématique autour du deuil donc
le deuil d'un attachement à une à une
place et cetera et qui vont avoir des
problématique du registre dépressif
c'est plutôt ce genre de de
problématiques qui vont avoir lieu pour
les victime directe et puis du coup on
va avoir les autres les autres personnes
qui n'ont peut-être pas encore fait
l'expérience directement dans leur vie
quotidienne d'avoir été impacté par le
dérèglement climatique à travers un
événement climatique extrême mais qui
ont cette inquiétude parce que il y a
cette confrontation avec les
informations qui sont à notre
disposition il faut savoir quand même
que tous en fait en réalité on a fait
l'expérience du dérèglement climatique
ne serait-ce qu'à travers les les les
épisodes de canicule il faut savoir que
lors des épisodes caniculair il y a une
augmentation de la fréquentation des
urgences psychiatriques qui fait x 7
donc c'est fois SEP passages aux
urgences psychiatriques il y a des
décompensations qui sont plus fréquentes
euh pour nos patients donc des patients
qui ont des troubles psychiatriques
connus qui lors des épisodes
caniculaires vont avoir des symptômes
qui vont s'augment qui vont augmenter et
qui vont nécessiter euh des prises en
charge et il faut savoir qu'il y a un
risque de mortalité qui est multiplié
par trois pour nos patients pendant les
les épisodes caniculaires donc tous en
fait on a déjà été confronté aux effets
du dérèglement climatique dans notre
propre chair puisque là ça fait
plusieurs étés que on traverse des
épisodes caniculaires ça ça a été assez
bien documenté c'est pas exactement le
sujet du jour mais c'est pour dire que
en fait nous on sur notre territoire on
a un peu des deux il y a des territoires
sur lesquels en fait les populations
elles ont été projetées directement dans
la confrontation à des épisodes
climatique extrême à la la la
précarisation des ressources le fait
qu'il n'y a plus de ressources en autre
plus de de ressources en nourriture le
fait que les conditions de survie de
base ne sont plus ne sont plus assurer
qu'il y a des conflits qui qui existent
de ce fait-là et qui doivent bouger de
territoire pour pouvoir assurer leur
survie donc effectivement il y a une
part de culturelle c'est-à-dire que on
peut se poser ces questions parce qu'on
est encore relativement préservé mais ce
relativement préservé devient de plus en
plus discutable et de plus en plus
précaire y a des complé de
rép euh alors
oui pour la la j'essaie de j'ai
rassembler mes idées pour la question
sur l'hypersensibilité émotionnelle et
et l'écoanxiété il y a pas d'étude qui
pourrait valider ça ce que je peux faire
c'est un retour de mes collègues terrain
et moi-même et je vais reprendre une une
histoire raconé é enfin une anecdote
raconté par le le professeur Christophe
André qui est également
psychiatre sur les les les Canaris dans
les mines de grisou avec l'idée que
lorsque les mineurs descendaient et il y
avait le risque du coup du grisou du
coup du grisou et ils descendaient avec
leur Canaris qui étit plus sensible au
grisou queeux et donc du coup lorsqu'il
voyait un canari tourner de l'œil il il
filait en gros pour éviter effectivement
de de se retrouver exposé à ce gaz qui
était mortel il y a l'idée du coup
derrière un petit peu que les
hypersensibles pourrai être
effectivement plus rapidement on va dire
affectés ou touché par ces questions là
mais ils sont à comprendre un peu comme
ces Canaries c'estàd un peu comme des
lanceurs d'alerte avec l'idée de dire
certes peut-être qu'ils expriment
quelque chose mais c'est quelque chose
le gaz est bien mortel pour tout le
monde donc voilà c'est pour dire il y a
quelque chose qui pourrait tous nous
toucher par rapport à ça un petit peu
comme vient de le pointer cé Massini par
rapport à la question de de la
résilience ça me semble vraiment être le
point principal effectivement peut-être
à retenir par rapport au à ce qui
pourrait être proposé c'est-à-dire il on
va être confronté indéiablement de plus
en plus à des des situations de plus en
plus difficiles on va dire
psychologiquement à faire face que ça
soit des inondation des feux enfin voilà
peu importe des canicules et donc il est
important de travailler on revient sur
la question de la prévention de
travailler sur l'idée d'un une
préparation psychologique on va dire à
ces questionsl par des compag des
campagnes de prévention mais du coup
fait avec des personnes spécialisées
quand même sur l'accompagnement
émotionnel je reviens là-dessus et pas
faire ça avec des jeunes qui qui en gros
on va leur dire c'est vous la génération
qui allait vous occuper de ça qui se
retrouve complètement écrasée par ça et
ça va avoir un effet complètement
inverse donc ça faut savoir que ça ça
c'est déjà arrivé donc cette notion de
de résilience est vraiment essentielle
et enfin sur la question de
l'écoradicalité qui serait du coup une
réponse pathologique j'aurais surtout
envie de dire que mon mon mon
appréhension venant à la table ronde
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui était qu'on se
centre sur l'écoanxiété comme quelque
chose qu'il faud résoudre à un niveau
juste sanitaire alors que j'aurais envie
de dire et je pense qu'on perdrait
beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup de temps
euh alors que je pense que la réponse
doit être double bien évidemment il faut
qu'il y ait de la prévention pour
s'assurer une certaine façon que les
personnes tiennent face à un petit peu
tous les changements qui V qui vont
arriver et donc qu' ait quelque chose
d'une résilience psychologique par
rapport à ça mais je pense vraiment que
c'est essentiel que sur d'autres
terrains il y ait des vraies mises en
action et qu'
une communication claire et franche
là-dessus afin que d'une certaine façon
les personnes n'en viennent pas à une
écoradicalité n'en viennent pas parce
que sinon si on commence à essayer de
résoudre ce souci individu par individu
dans dans notre cabinet on va pas y
arriver on va perdre le temps voilà
c'est c'est vraiment ce que je voulais
dire
merci une une dernière question
peut-être si vous permettez Daniel
Chassin merci monsieur le Président
merci aux
intervenants donc si vous
voulez euh on a un dérèglement
climatique qui qui entraîne des anxiétés
on le voit avec les tornad ça a été les
inondations les feux l'augmentation de
clavicule de la canicule
alors
actuellement nous voyons malgré les
accords de Paris
certaines certains pays comme la Chine
qui pollue à 33 % au niveau
international la France moin de 1 % et
euh l'Europe je crois 4 ou 5
% donc
l'Europe l'Europe l'Union européenne
dans les pays de l'Union européenne on a
une diminution de l'émission de gaz à
effet de serre et en France aussi de
près de 5 % donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est plutôt un peu
rassurant est-ce que les les personnes
euh voit dans ces diminutions de
d'émissions effet de ser quelque chose
de quand même plutôt positif même si
bien sûr ils ne peuvent pas influer sur
les gros pollueurs l'Inde la Chine les
États-Unis l'Australie l'Afrique du Sud
qui développe beaucoup le le charbon
actuellement mais en Europe aussi on est
obligé d'avoir des entreprises pour que
dans des pays comme la France notamment
bien on puisse conserver nos acquis
sociaux nous avons vous savez des une
augmentation des déficits au niveau de
de la sécurité sociale et on souhaite
tous conserver même augmenter nos acquis
sociaux donc il faut pour de la
prévention et la
prévention c'est d'avoir une énergie
décarbonée je crois que c'est ce qui se
fait en France avec l'énergie nucléaire
développement des gergies
hydroélectrique et et autres est-ce que
ça c'est pas quelque chose qui est quand
même plutôt rassurant et qui est qui
peut diminuer l'écho anxiété merci
oui alors c'est c'est très intéressant
vous pointiez ces ces ces informations
qui qu'on pourrait taxer de positive et
c'est tout l'enjeu justement d'un
travail thérapeutique c'est d'arrêter de
faire en sorte que les éconxieux se
focalisent sur les informations
négatives parce que des chararg l'ont
montré hein on est aimanté 2,7 fois
c'est très précis plus par les
informations négatives que positives et
évidemment face aux enjeux climatiques
pour lequels on a pas prise directement
parce qu'on a en nous une mécanique qui
est la mécanique du stress qui nous
permet de gérer et de faire face à à des
dangers des enjeux sur lesquels on a des
ressources mais face à la banquise on n'
pas la ressource dame nature n'a pas mis
en nous cette ressource donc il y a
d'autresessources qui sont effectivement
euh des ressources cognitives et et et
et clairement et c'est ce que je
présente dans dans cet ouvrage bien
vivre son éch-anxiété puisque ça comme
vous voyez c'est quelque chose de
positif comme titre que j'ai coécrit
avec Sylvie Chan Berlin c'est d'aller
faire des listes des bonnes nouvelles au
regard des des mauvaises nouvelles hein
de qui s'accumulent dans les médias et
peut-être que ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel vous pourriez rfléchir c'est
faire en sorte que les médias diffusent
des bonnes nouvelles et les bonnes
nouvelles sont hyper importante parce
que elle permett une régulation
cognitive et donc de contrebalancer
parce que il y a une homéostasie interne
dans dans dans dans dans la psyché qui
fait qu'on a deux plateaux des
sollicitations négatives des
sollicitations positives il faut
absolument contrebalancer les
solitations négatives par des
sollicitation positiv et les
informations positives sont une bonne
manière de contrebalancer les
informations négatives et moi je fais
faire des listes à mes patients de
bonnes nouvelles alors ça un premier
effet c'est de contrebalancé mais il y a
un deuxième effet c'est d'identifier
aussi des écoot témoins de de personnes
qui ont fait des choses positives pour
la planète auxquel les les les
écooncieux peuvent s'identifier pour
pour avoir une une perspective optimiste
d'une action qui contrebalance aussi les
effets négatifs de de de de de nos de
nos activités consuméristes et je je
cite souvent l'exemple de Félix finbiner
qui est un jeune allemand d'une
vingtaine d'années qui à l'âge de 9 ans
est effrayé c'était il y a une quinzaine
d'années à peu près est effrayé par la
déforestation amazonienne et il se dit
quand je serai grand je planterai un
milliard d'arbres alors tout le monde le
regarde un peu de haut en disant écoute
va jouer au dans ta course c'est un peu
n'importe quoi sauf son prof qui lui dit
son enseignant qui dit et ben moi je
crois à ton projet je vais t'aider à
planter ton premier arme et tu vas le
faire avec tes petits camarades et là il
a une révélation félixingbiner il se dit
ah ouais c'est possible mais il va
falloir que j'en plante plein d'autres
et je vais pas y arriver tout seul donc
il y a des parents qui l'aident un peu
puisqu'ils sont entrepreneurs il va
fonder sa première ONG et à l'âge de 13
ans on le voit à la tribune de le de
l'ONU demander des subsides qu'il va
obtenir et il va pas planter un milliard
d'arbres il va en planter 14 milliards
il en est à 14 milliards et son ambition
c'est d'en planter 100
milliards et 100 milliards c'est un/ers
des arbres aujourd'hui il y a 300 il y a
300 milliards d'arbres sur Terre on en a
déforesté 300 300 milliards
depuis la la révolution technologie la
révolution industrielle merci et lui il
veut compenser à lui tout seul un/4 en
rajouter un/4 donc ça fera un/4 de de de
ces arbres d'ici la fin de donc à
l'impossible nul n'est tenu mais on peut
arriver à faire des choses si bien sûr
on déploie quelque chose qui s'appuie
sur le collectif et les états on peut
arriver si on aligne l'individuel le
collectif et euh le sociétal mais pour
ça il faut pas qu'il y ait des
incohérences ou des conflits entre ces
différents niveaux faut qu'il y ait
vraiment un alignement des énergies et
on arrivera à faire des choses justement
avec les énergies renouvelables
l'énergies nucléaire à court terme parce
qu'elle présent d'autres d'autres
problème qui physiquement et je parle
pas des aspects idéologiques peuvent
nous permettre de remporter la victoire
de euh euh de de la de la transposition
des énergies fossiles aux énergies non
polluantes et et non dangereuses pour
l'humanité voilà ben je crois qu'on va
conclure sur ce message sur ce dernier
mot collectif et et et volonté politique
pour ce qui nous concerne
d'accompagnement dans dans cette
transition pour que nos concitoyens se
portent mieux voilà Jean un petit mot
peut-être vous merci à intervenant vous
remerciez de de la qualité de de ces
débats et des éclairages que vous avez
pu nous apporter souhaitons une bonne
journée merci merci à
tous